Governor Joe Lombardo was in town today
touting his education agenda at Mountain
View Christian Schools 8 news now
reporter Brian will spoke with the
governor today and tells us what this
bill is all about and what opponents are
saying Brian yeah Brian assembly Bill
400 would send tax dollars to a
scholarship program that would pay for
students tuition at private schools
that's just part of what is in this bill
the governor is hoping will pass this
session
there are academic future is very
important to me without this financial
assistance I would not know how I would
be immigrant me to ensure that their
learning needs were met I went from a
struggling student that uses Lexia as an
excuse to an A B student that uses by
dyslexia to my advantage Republican
Governor Joe Lombardo held a Roundtable
on Monday to hear from students and
parents in favor of school choice Bill
AB 400 Lombardo says the state is a
victim of its own success with a rapid
growing population along with its
growing class sizes he says bringing in
more choices will help with this problem
and if you bring school choice into the
mechanism you expand that number of
infrastructure that is available to the
process or to the problem and eventually
you'll continue to build that out as we
work for it Democrats against the bill
say the scholarships which range from
around eight to twelve thousand dollars
each would go to families who could
already afford a private education the
bill would make scholarships eligible
for families who make up to 150 000 a
year funding for these opportunity
scholarships would grow from 25 million
right now to a projected 500 million
that would be in addition to the 2
billion in funding for public education
a big part of it in this bill as for
what the governor says to those who
oppose the bill I've given you the
ability to fund it with a two billion
dollar injection into this budget cycle
there's no excuses to be had so what is
the other solution outside of the
funding is opportunity and choice
so far that bill has had a hearing but
currently hasn't had a vote on it yet